good afternoon everyone I'm Elizabeth
stout ermine I'm the chief
communications officer at Yale
University and I want to thank you all
for coming to this momentous occasion to
introduce Yale's most recent Nobel
laureate Robert Shiller sterling
professor of economics and professor of
Finance we will you'll find press
materials regarding this and the other
announcements that we make on our
website we encourage you to go to new
Zelda U for updates about everything
that happens at Yale you can also
contact my colleague Amy Athey McDonald
who's raising her hand right now if you
have any requests for one-on-one
interviews with Professor Shiller who is
as you can imagine a very popular man
this morning the way that will make this
press conference go is that you will
first hear from the chair of Economics
Douglas and Marian Campbell professor of
economics and computer science dirk
bergen professor burgum on will
introduce Dean
Ted Snyder of the Yale School of
Management and Ted Snyder will introduce
president Peter Salovey and Peter Salome
will introduce Professor Shiller and we
ask that you hold your questions until
after the presentations have been made
and also if you could speak your
questions loudly so that we can hear it
this event is being live-streamed thank
you very much for coming
thank you well as chair of the Akuma at
Department of Economics it's of course
my great pleasure to welcome you all to
join us in celebrating the reception and
the Nobel Prize for Bob Shiller today
bob has been a member of the department
of economics since 1982 and today he was
awarded a Nobel Prize for his work in
the analysis of empirical asset pricing
jointly together was Eugene fama and
last Peter Hanson from the University of
Chicago it was said Bob Shiller's County
the Sterling professor of economics at
Yale this is the highest academic rank
that the University awards to his
professors and has been with us since
1982 Bob received his BA from the
University of Michigan in 1967 and his
PhD in 1972 from MIT already with a
dissertation topic on a surprising name
entitled rational expectations and the
structure of interest rates and that was
under the dissertation of Franco
Modigliani as well a Nobel Prize winner
for me the range of Bob's work is really
astounding and was an incredible reach
over many fields and resourced
methodologies and he doesn't rest in
that respect and already his list of
publications is sort of a small book by
itself and let me just mention among his
earlier contributions that made really
lasting mark and is the paper the starts
was a question do stock prices move too
much to be justified by subsequent
changes in dividends now it sounds like
a a rather technical but yet fundamental
questions to the entire class of our
basic understanding of financial markets
and asset pricing and this paper which
was published in 1981 in the American
Economic Review really led slowly but
very surely to a turn in our
understanding of financial markets in
particular to behavioural turn in
financial markets and it still has a
lasting impression and you will see his
academic work really when
on and on but from my point of view what
is the most impressive is how he
translates his deep theoretical
understandings in markets in economics
and then to an understanding of how can
we create instruments policies that
really have the scope and the potential
to improve a society's welfare so just
to give you one of the more prominent
example and this is really rare for an
economist so it's even more distinct in
that sense in 1991 Bob created with his
colleague helicase an index for house
prices that was developed further and
then actually implemented and it's now
quoted inside the daily by Standard and
Poor's and five serves that was simply
meant to capture the evolution of house
prices but that was of course just the
basic idea to start something much
larger and that he expanded in a
beautiful book which was called macro
markets creating institutions for
managing society's largest economic
risks that really developed the theme of
how we can find instruments to diversify
and ensure a large swath of the
population against many of the risks
that they actually uninsured so in that
sense it is really academic work that
had the deepest reach into the ability
to actually develop policies that can
help the citizens in the US but globally
of course and he continues to propose
new methods to risk management which are
not only helpful for world super V D are
helpful for means if you want me to say
it in that way okay this line of work
has been very influential and of course
it also makes him very popular teacher
at Yale he teaches many classes at Yale
a very popular class in introduction to
financial markets and this year an
introduction to macroeconomics which
will be attended by our freshmen and
sophomores and so that just shows you
the the fascination that Bob can also
invoke as a teacher of the history
search and probably he will have even
more students now in the upcoming
I should also say that he was one of the
earliest teachers to develop or create
open course material and particularly
his course on financial markets and he's
going to develop a new course on
Coursera in the spring that will be
already subscribed to by several hundred
thousand students so it's really an
amazing influence in reach and so my
hope is that this line of work which was
very influential but will become even
more impactful with this award of the
prize to Bob and so that his insights
will really help us at large to develop
better means to to ensure and develop a
global good so thank you and it's my
great pleasure to have bokkeum on
yesterday Ted Snyder the Dean of the
business school would say a few words
about Professor Bergman thank you very
much I thought your comments were most
insightful president Sall of a professor
Shiller it's really wonderful honor for
me to be here it's quite an amazing day
for Yale and for Chicago and just on a
personal note I have a I have the great
honor of knowing all three laureates
having been dean at the Business School
of Chicago prior to my appointment to
Yale
just a bit of just two years ago and I'm
very happy for Lars Hanson my former
neighbor and for my very dear colleague
gene fama it's really an exciting day
for for all three recipients and I'm
also mindful of the fact that there was
a guy sitting in the back of gene famous
class David Booth who decades ago
listened to gene and implemented his
ideas and I'm sure David is very pleased
today but today here at Yale is about
Bob Shiller
and I like to just add to Professor
Bergman's comment
and it's interesting he and I didn't
coordinate but it it just shows you that
it's quite clear Bob Shiller is the
leader of and indeed the the founder of
the field of behavioral finance that's
the that's the consensus view and it
starts with the paper cited already the
1981 American Economic Review paper and
I'll state the question a little bit
differently but I think it's worth worth
stating and it's a very important
fundamental question when we look at a
stock price what does it depend on and a
lot of people said that the stock price
depended on what profits the firm was
expected to earn over time and then how
those profits would be discounted and
then if stock if in fact stock prices
depended on that on those factors then
changes in stock prices would
necessarily reflect changes in the
expected profits or the discounting well
this is this was the tenant this was the
belief but it was Bob Shiller who said
well let's test it let's see if it's
true and let's look at actual stock
price movements and see if they in fact
are explained by this dis formula this
relationship and what he found was stock
prices change much more so than what you
could explain by changes in profits or
changes in the discounting mechanism
that began the field of behavioral
economics and his intellectual
leadership in this field has had a
profound effect on the academic world
it's had a profound effect on the world
of practice and I were we at the Yale
School of Management where he has a
joint appointment have benefited greatly
and as Dean I'm mindful
that he has indeed had a profound impact
on our school and I just like to
identify a few of those contributions
professor Shiller co-leads with
Professor Nick barbarous the Yale PhD
summer camp on behavioral finance he's
an active member of the Yale School of
Management International Finance Center
he has been collecting and analyzing
data on investor expectations over the
long term it's a project financed and
supported by white box advisors when his
most recent book came out finance and
the good Society I met with Professor
Shiller and he agreed to give a series
of Yale School of Management lectures on
the book he is in great demand and of
course will now be in yet greater demand
in terms of various audiences for the
school students alumni friends and
what's really nice is that he's been
very generous with his time to all those
audiences on January 11th he'll be part
of an opening opening conference at the
Yale School of Management when we open
our new campus Evans Hall and the topic
will be financed in society markets and
behaviors he'll be joined by David
Swensen chief investment officer for
Yale Jane Mondello
chief investment officer for Harvard
will guest Minh our colleague in finance
and zebu Chen also our colleague in
finance I thought you did a great job in
covering the role of the Case Shiller
index I won't repeat that it's it's it's
noteworthy that both professor fama and
professor Shiller have generated a lot
of very practical empirical work this is
unusual for academics and I think it's
great testimony to each of them and if
we didn't have the Case Shiller index we
probably wouldn't have anywhere near as
much insight as
now into the question of financial
crises and the potential for bubbles
last thing I want to do is say sort of a
shout out to the all the MBAs Yale MBAs
who had the great fortune of taking the
course offered throughout the university
that bob has offered behavioral and
institutional economics a lot of very
smart Yale MBAs were astute enough to
say let's go over and take Bob Shiller's
class thank you and now president Peter
salivate
Thank You Dean Snider thank you all for
being here I know you want to hear from
our laureate so I will be brief you know
I have to thank the Prize Committee but
especially professor Shiller because
it's not every day that the Yale
president is able to stand before the
press and say I'd like to announce today
and introduce you to a Nobel laureate
from Yale it's not every day we can do
that it's just every Monday that we can
do that so thank you Dirk for those
comments Thank You Ted for yours this is
a great day for our University and I am
delighted that in one week's time we are
able to stand on two sides of campus on
the medical school side of our campus Oh
celebrating the award of the Nobel Prize
in Physiology or medicine to Professor
Jim Rothman the chair of our cell
biology department and then today to be
able to celebrate with our friend and
colleague Bob Shiller sterling professor
of economics and professor of Finance on
the announcement of his receipt of the
Nobel Prize in Economics
we also have other aspects of the
economics world that we will be able to
celebrate this year this week that
connect to yell for example the
announcement of Janet Yellen who is a
distinguished graduate of our Department
of Economics as the nominee to head the
Federal Reserve this is really all very
exciting to me two Nobel Prizes Janet
Yellen and of course this was the week
in which I was formally inaugurated as
yells 23rd president and for me to be
able to celebrate with such
distinguished colleagues and really
celebrate their achievements is as
exciting for a new president I think as
anything that could have happened on
this campus you know I have to say
although Bob's home department is
economics and although he teaches and
has an appointment in our School of
Management I must say that Professor
Schiller's approach includes ideas from
my own field social psychology and in
fact the field of behavioral finance and
now more generally behavioral economics
really is one of a merging of two
underlying disciplines work in social
psychology particularly in a sub area
called judgment and decision making
merging with and influencing traditional
economic models to suggest variables
that need to be attended to if we are
really to have a true understanding of
bubbles of collapses of other economic
phenomenon economic phenomenon is at the
end of the day at least from this
psychologists perspective driven by
human behavior and it is Bob Shiller who
has made all of us whether it's an
economics
finance or in psychology more and more
aware of this so his work is really
quite synthetic and quite
cross-disciplinary in its in its
approach now the other thing I have to
mention that Professor Shiller shares
with Professor Rothman as these two as
our two Nobel laureates in a week's time
is that in addition to being incredible
scholars and researchers in their own
field both of them are incredible
teachers as you've heard from Professor
Bergman professor Shiller is teaching
the introductory microeconomics course
this spring he will probably have three
hundred and fifty students at least that
was our estimate before today's events
and to imagine you are an undergraduate
at Yale probably a freshman or a
sophomore and you are taking
macroeconomics a course that sometimes
has perplexed freshmen and sophomores
and you are taking it now from a Nobel
prize-winner
nothing could be more exciting I think
in a student's life and nothing could
represent what we are trying to
accomplish here at Yale University in
suggesting that brilliant world leading
research and excellence in teaching are
not opposite sides of a coin but
actually can be conducted together I
have to mention that Professor Shiller
also is offering a course to the general
public through Coursera that is entirely
free and will begin in January 2014
although you can register for it right
now
and this is a course in financial
markets that I'm sure will be excellent
well I know that you all want to meet
our Nobel Prize winner I know many of
you know him from especially from his
book irrational exuberance but maybe
from many others I know that he has been
a force in educating both the scholar
the student and the layperson alike
about finance and about the human
behavior that gives rise to interesting
financial phenomena and so let me not
delay any longer and introduce to you
our latest Nobel Prize winner this time
in economics professor Robert Shiller
well I'm still in disbelief I'm
certainly honored by this event I'm
starting to wonder how I'm going to live
up to the expectations that people now
have of me
so yes it's correct I'm going to be
teaching the intro macroeconomics course
here next semester and populated heavily
by freshmen the problem is our chairman
dirk told me that freshmen tend to be
very critical of their professors
especially in these big classes with
hundreds of students so I'm viewing that
as a challenge so yeah I have a certain
disbelief maybe it's because of a habit
of thought that I tend to think of my
own work as a minor addendum to a huge
body of work that others have generated
and so I had the idea that I would list
my co-authors there's only 22 of them I
went through my Vita and I think I
missed when I'll be horrified but George
Akerlof Stefano asana Sulis aundrea belt
rowdy by the way this list you'll note
how international these people are all
over the planet now Maxime Boyko Oliver
Bund John Campbell Karl case ray fair
he's here at Yale Sandford Grossman
g---men Jung Fumiko Cunha Vladimir Cora
Bob Randall Kroszner Franco Modigliani
Pierre Peron John pound John Quigley Kim
Sean Holtz Jeremy Siegel Yoshi otsutsuki
Eric van Wynkoop and Alan Weiss that's
22 co-authors I want to thank them on
this occasion because they contributed
to my work but it's not just my
co-authors it's also
all the other people in our department
and in other departments that I've
worked with including I might add the co
Nobel Prize winners I was going to send
them a congratulation this morning it's
just too hectic but I'm going to and I'm
thinking that their work might seem
different from mine as Dirk was saying
I've been involved with behavioral
economics and behavioral finance which
is more psychologically oriented but on
the other side of it I've always been a
lover of mathematics and and theory that
represents a different approach to
economics and I think if you were to
compare my work with Jean Fama's or Lars
Hanson look at them side-by-side you'd
see a lot of similarities as well I'm
interested in the same mathematical
concepts and Lars Hanson was testing
some of the same models which are
rational models and by the way he
rejected them so he didn't come around
saying you were right about behavior but
he did reject the models so so Peter
Salovey pointed out that I have been
more had involved in interdepartmental
efforts not that I show up regularly at
all these other departments but I was
thinking that psychology has had a huge
impact probably because of my wife Jenny
who is seated there who is a
psychologist at the Yale child studies
Center and I talked with her more than
any other person and I'm sure she has
shaped my work in a fundamental way but
I'm thinking it's not just the
psychology department
the management school represents a
intellectual see I think that there's
many different intellectual approaches
to the basic questions that people want
answered people develop certain ways of
thinking about them so the management
school for example has a marketing
department which is almost a second
psychology department but with a
different focus and then there are other
departments in the university of the
sociology department I used to ask maybe
Peter can explain what's the difference
between sociology and social psychology
I think I have an idea but it's it's
deep in the motivations of the and the
habits of research that differ then
there's the political science department
there's the history department
there's the statistics department and
the law school which I liked also to
mention I really have over the years
growing an increasing appreciation for
our law school and law in general it's
it's a it's a discipline which i think
is closely related to economics but it's
very real world very real world oriented
and then there are other departments to
the fade away and relevance to what I do
but still are relevant so that's the
thing I wanted to express my
appreciation to all these people
so I've been involved in particularly in
a movement called behavioral economics
and I've been organizing workshops with
George Akerlof and with Richard Thaler
for 20 years now but I don't mean to be
doctrinaire about that it's not another
cult I don't I don't believe in in
schools of thought I think it's all
approaches that they have their unique
advantages and we want to try to learn
from all of them I should say something
about yeah I was attracted to this
department over 30 years ago what was it
it was the kind of intellectual breadth
and depth that I saw here James Tobin
was among the people who particularly
impressed me
and not just for intellectual death but
it's for morality
I thought Tobin and others here were
particularly moral people it's a matter
of getting yourself in getting your real
values integrated with your research I
think it's significant that Janet Yellen
who was just nominated by President
Obama for the Fed chair is also a very
moral person I believe and she did her
dissertation under Tobin so I can see a
line of descent for this these attitudes
so I thought I would just say a couple
more words about finance and the field
where the prize for all three of us this
year was in asset markets which is a
branch of finance I think that finance
should it's it's often misunderstood as
they feel about how to make money how to
get rich I have to tell my students here
that's not how I think of it finance is
the study of human activity of human
activity at large just about any useful
thing that we would like to get done
involves groups of people and it evolves
time it's an activity that has to be
consistently pursued over years of time
people will come and go well this is
management but it's also finance finance
is about well financing activities that
means making the resources available
incentivizing people spreading the risks
these any useful thing is likely to have
risks and that's what that's what I
think we are about here in particular I
think that we have important risks and
problems going forward that improvement
in our financial institutions can help
solve I've mentioned first of all it's
not the financial crisis per se
but the most important problem that we
are facing now today I think is rising
inequality in the United States and
elsewhere in the world this is a problem
that has solutions many of them are
financial solutions finance is
substantially about risk management and
if it's applied right if it's
democratized that means if it's the real
tools are made useful to real people and
not to just a minority of people it can
help solve these problems I'll stop with
that and then we have open for questions
the shutdown and the deficit well this
is a political science question and I
guess sometimes people ask me what do
you think the effects on financial
markets will be but let me let me first
say in deference to our law professors
you should really be asking a expert in
constitutional law because the
particular crisis transcends the
immediate it's about how we're going to
do things in Congress how will the
government reach consensus I'll defer to
others on that very important question I
hate to do this I like to go to the
essence of your question but I feel in
this case I could instead comment on
what it will do to financial markets and
I'm thinking probably nothing big is
going to happen it's all it should be
okay that's partly a political science
debt this is how you can't divide things
up it's it's my sense that we still have
in this country a sense of cooperation
that will emerge and prevent a default
but I can think about what happened
we've been through this before
notably in 2011 remember it was August 2
of 2011 that was targeted as a date when
we would run out of money and default
and then on on the very eve of default
Congress finally came through and that
we did not default that time then
however on August 5th Friday of 2011
after the markets closed Standard &
Poor's did an unprecedented step of
downgrading the US debt away from
triple-a status that following Monday
the stock market S&P 500 fell 7% in one
day it looked like and there was a lot
of noise around it it's a strange event
because leading up to this crisis the
market was before August
was rather quiet then it gets it's after
the downgrade that it got wild so what
happened well I think that the downgrade
shook the sense of confidence of
Americans in their own institutions
there was a it was a shock to think that
we're not a triple-a country anymore
on the other hand the market has gone up
a lot since then and so even now it
wasn't so fundamental so that's why I'm
thinking that this crisis will likely be
resolved we won't see a default in even
if we do it will be for one day or
something like that and even if it's
longer I think that it's not it's not
the end of the world and the markets
might drop 7% on some day and then come
back up
I should add however I do not know the
future and I could be wrong
yeah yeah the thing is that there there
is a unity of knowledge that there's so
many factors that affect the stock
market that people don't think about the
stock market is deeply political you
have to remember that we have for
example a corporate profits tax and
Congress raises and lowers that it's
been up and down when they raise the tax
to something like 50 percent that's like
nationalizing half the stock market and
then when they cut it again it's it's
it's it's reverse that and it's not just
the corporate profits tax there's so
many things the government does so I
think that's one reason why the market
is probably less unstable than it would
seem based on some theories that exclude
political science if you remember that
our congressmen are interested in the
confidence that Americans feel and do
not want to see crises in the financial
markets we can expect them to do
something that's more stabilizing though
the problem is in answering questions
about such deep and important questions
it brings you across all of the
different fields of social science and
and beyond
well I've been writing what are called
popular books or trade books I don't
I like to call them scholarly trade
books it's not a question just of
speaking to the general public I think
if one writes well it can often be
accessible to the general public but the
kind of popular books that I've tried to
write our big picture type books that
put it together in a way that that you
couldn't get by reading scholarly
articles it's so in some sense there's
summaries of what people are doing but I
don't feel that they're just a summary I
feel that a well-written trade book
scholarly trade book is something that
ties different things together in an
intuitive way presents a worldview and
something you wouldn't do to a
professional to a scholar you can do for
the public and hope that the scholar
reads it anyway so I was giving an
example at a talk I gave last week in
Princeton about how people don't connect
things they know so I was with Ginny on
clam Island where we were watching out
in the Long Island sign where we were
watching a sunset and I was asked with
various other people and I stopped to
ask them do you know what you're
watching here what is this phenomenon a
sunset and they they looked puzzled what
do you mean I said well do you reflect
for a moment that we are moving
backwards at 600 miles an hour as the
Earth turns and we're losing sight of a
million mile in diameter ball and that o
on top of that the earth is plunging at
down that way at 66,000 miles an hour in
its orbit around the Sun I I don't think
they knew that
I mean they know that they know that
intellectually but they don't integrate
it into their thinking and that's partly
what I what I do to answer your question
in writing a popular book yeah well I'm
I'm not the first one to raise this
issue that inequality has been getting
worse for decades economic inequality
and it could get much worse
we don't know maybe it'll just correct
itself but these are hard things to
forecast but I'm reminded of the MIT
mathematician Norbert Wiener who in the
late 1940s wrote one of the first books
on computer science the title of the
book was cybernetics and he it was a
very mathematical technical treatise on
computers but in the last chapter of the
book he had some philosophical thoughts
and he said that he's worried about the
computer because it has the potential to
replace human intelligence in fact
Wiener said that he thought that he
didn't know what is more dangerous the
atom bomb or the computer that was just
a couple years after the Hiroshima and
Nagasaki disasters but it's true if if
computers are replacing many kinds of
things that people are skilled to do
that's an issue we don't know where it's
going to go and that doesn't necessarily
have to work out that way but I think
it's a risk that we'll see greater
inequality in in 10 20 30 50 a hundred
years and we have to think I think we
should think about this one thing that
I've said in my in in my recent books we
should be thinking about this now not
wait until after it happens even though
we don't know that it's going to get
worse so I'm here's where I think
finance training helps me it's a risk
it's certainly a risk that this trend is
get much worse you'd hardly hear people
discussing that but what we're supposed
to be trained to do in finance is to
think about risks and how to manage them
and there are tools for risk management
so in particular I've advocated and
actually this was picked up by Ian Ayres
at the Yale Law School in a New York
Times column he wrote he and I are both
advocating that we have a contingency
plan in place now to raise taxes on the
rich
if inequality gets worse they won't like
it but I'll tell you they'll know
they'll accept it much more willingly if
it's done in advance as a contingency
plan then if we wait until it happens
and then try to be try to fix it yes
well I was getting out of the shower I
wasn't properly dressed but I didn't
want to miss the phone call so I took it
in our kitchen that's where I was and I
yeah and it was quite a quite a surprise
what had happened I I certainly didn't
expect it oh I called my brother yeah
well I thought my brother sleeps in and
he might actually not know in Detroit so
I called him and I said did you hear the
news and he says the Tigers lost
everyone else called me that's the only
person I called my brother yes
mm-hmm right well you you mentioned two
things the stock market and the housing
market yeah it's true the Fed has
embarked on the most expansionary
monetary policy ever it's not just low
interest rate well the interest rates
have been it's virtually zero and on top
of that quantitative easing that's
caused the Fed to raise their balance
sheet up to almost four trillion dollars
that's more than four times bigger than
it was before this crisis so it's very
aggressive and it's not surprising it
would have affect the stock market is
rather highly priced and there's
different ways of metric I know this is
controversial but work that I've done
with John Campbell and has we've
developed a price earnings ratio called
caper cyclically adjusted price earnings
ratio that is right standing now around
24 which i think is high but not as high
as it was in 2000 when i published my
book irrational exuberance it was 46
then more than but almost twice as high
as it is now so I don't think that one
should view it with alarm and one one
could well invest and and probably
should in a diversified portfolio invest
in stocks but I worry that it might be
it it might correct down it's a it's not
a sure thing at this point the second
thing is the housing market housing has
corrected down in real terms from its
peak according to the S&P case-shiller
index by almost 50% since its peak in
2006 and it's up now itself about 18% in
real terms from the bottom in March of
2012
so it appears to be correcting up the
question is whether it's a new boom or
even a new bubble and I think this is
still an unanswered question the
interesting thing is that bubbles in the
housing market or bubble like phenomena
are not confined to the US
and in fact we have what people call
real estate bubbles in lots of countries
now like for example China Taiwan Hong
Kong Australia New Zealand India where
am I going
Belgium Norway UK United States Canada
Mexico Brazil Chile I might have left
out somebody but that's my list of
country now I don't necessarily know
that those are bubbles but I'm just
saying that people in those countries
say that so it's happening in so many
places it's hard to it's hard to
understand all of these phenomena what I
think is that after the financial crisis
or starting around 2000 before the
financial crisis the world became more
speculative about real estate it used to
be not considered something to worry
about home fire unless you lived in
Manhattan or a rare unusual place or
London face like that but now people
worry everywhere it's a cultural change
that I think will tend to bring
volatility for years to come
and I think it's a suitable function of
central bank's to try to lean against
this volatility which they're starting
to do and we have to we have to consider
that but it's it is it's a psychological
chain or a sociological change that on
the other hand let me just say about the
United States home prices are not high
yet here they've got a long way to go
before they're like they were in 2006 I
do with the support of the Yale School
of Management I do serve it we just did
a survey of home buyers and ask them
their expectations for home prices and
depending on how you quantify their or
summarize their expectations it seems
that Americans today who have just
bought a house thinking that
home market will be back up to its 2006
peak sometime in the 2030s or 2040 s I'm
reporting what they say homebuyers are
not excitedly optimistic about the
longer run they think in the short run
they're going up but they think that it
might be just a rebound and momenta say
also the advent of professional
investors like Blackstone Group which
now owns 36 thousand homes we're seeing
more professional involvement it
reflects a change in the market it's not
clear that it's the same thing that was
happening eight years ago when we saw
the housing market booming I'd say it's
probably not the same thing it has a
different outlook not so optimistic for
homebuyers yeah
he asked whether the financial crisis
adequately addressed that is I tend to
take a very long historical sweep on
these things history of of the past
centuries has been a history of repeated
financial crises and repeated advances
made in response to these crises so for
example the Federal Reserve Act of 1913
was substantially a reaction to the
panic of 1907 and then the Securities
and Exchange Commission was a result of
the of the 1929 stock market crash a few
years later you know it doesn't happen
immediately and then this financial
crisis has given us the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau there are
all steps forward that seems to be
either way financial progress is made
it's it's slow and incremental and then
there was a crisis and then people are
willing to think about fundamental
changes the dodd-frank act in the United
States is the big the big thing and it
has done a number of good things but I
think there's a lot more to do so I
suggest you read my book new financial
order in 2003 or my book subprime
solution in 2008 I think there's a lot
more that can we can do and it will help
make a better society but some of the
things that I talked about in this book
you get these books but I should say
have actually happened in fact President
Obama several years ago announced a
student loan program that has income
based repayment that's progress that's
financial progress now and it's starting
in a small way but it's it goes back to
something that was started here at Yale
under the James Tobin in the 1970s Yale
University started a income contingent
loan student loan program right now
there's another little crisis not so
little in student loans it's a it's a
follow-on to the financial crisis that a
lot of people are having trouble
repaying there
in student loans the Yale Law School has
had a coke program so-called that has
student loans that are tied to
subsequent income so we're we're seeing
this is a source of pride for Yale to
have done at the very grounding of these
so I advocated these kinds of things
again in my book and now we have
President Obama proudly describing these
things in his speeches they're happening
but still not big enough I think we have
therefore more flexible financial
contracts that are more responsive to
people's needs
so he's asking what my policy
recommendations for Janet Yellen are
well first of all I've looked at some of
her recent speeches and read them
carefully and I just am very impressed
with her good sense and her recognition
of the important issues so I would
probably not presume to tell her what to
do that she has been a she done that
chairman of the Council of Economic
Advisers under under Clinton and then
president of the Federal Reserve Bank of
San Francisco and then vice president I
think she has a lot of expertise yeah
but you know I could just say general
things that someone in her position has
to look at the welfare of everyone I
don't think I have to tell her this that
I that I think that she views her job
correctly as a steward of our nation and
that means considering how economic
conditions could harm any of a number of
subgroups so we have the risk of
unemployment which is still with us we
still have we don't know what it is at
the moment because of the government
shutdown but it's something probably
over 7% unemployment that's terrible for
the people who don't have jobs this is
the thing I remember hearing Tobin my
mentor here at Yale say that it's real
suffering it's real problems that it's
not just at the dista tist ik on the
other hand though if if we become too
loose in our monetary policy and bring
on inflation that will hurt somebody
else the elderly for example who are
living on fixed incomes could be
seriously harmed by an outbreak of
inflation so I think that the one reason
why I've been such a strong supporter of
Janet for this position is that I think
her heart is in the right place and
she's observant about people